We're gonna get started.
NOTE CONF
Announcements.
Um, first, project number one is due tonight.
NOTE CONF
Remember, one person from your team should submit and link
all the group members.
NOTE CONF
And then Jon Johannes also sent out some instructions on
um assigning pages.
NOTE CONF
The diffusion assignment, which is project 2, has been released
and this Friday, Kai Fung will hold a discussion section
NOTE CONF
on project 2.
It'll be at Bor A 103B at 30 p.m. right?
NOTE CONF
And then on the agenda for today we're going to
be finishing our little primer on graphical models and then
NOTE CONF
we're gonna dive into the uh the the set up
for diffusion models and then do some derivations right.
NOTE CONF
Any questions on any course admin logistics?
OK, let me recap where we were from last time.
NOTE CONF
So last lecture I gave you this high level picture
of what diffusion does, which is our goal will be
NOTE CONF
to generate.
An image from a distribution like the images of dogs
NOTE CONF
and the way we're going to do this is we're
going to first corrupt an image by turning a dog
NOTE CONF
into unit Gaussian noise and.
After we do this forward diffusion process of turning the
NOTE CONF
dog into noise, we're going to reverse that process starting
from noise and then be able to basically subtract away
NOTE CONF
the noise to generate a dog at the output right?
so that's the high level idea of diffusion.
NOTE CONF
And then last lecture we said we'll need a few
tools to get there.
NOTE CONF
We have many of the tools, but one more thing
that we need is uh graphical models.
NOTE CONF
So we're doing this brief aside on graphical models.
This will be really important for understanding the diffusion derivation.
NOTE CONF
Uh, last lecture, we talked about graphical models where What
we have is we have nodes.
NOTE CONF
These are the circles with variables, random variables like A
and B, and then they're connected by links or edges.
NOTE CONF
And then we defined how from a graph you could
write down.
NOTE CONF
The probability density function of all the random variables.
So if I have 5 random variables X1, X2, X3,
NOTE CONF
X4X5, the way I write the probability of all of
them is to write the probability of each variable given
NOTE CONF
its parents.
So I start off with X1.
NOTE CONF
I write PFX1.
It has no parents.
NOTE CONF
PFX2 it has no parents PFX 3, it has no
parents.
NOTE CONF
Then PFX4 and X4's parents are X2 and X1 and
X3.
NOTE CONF
So it's PFX4 given it parents which are X1 X2
X3.
NOTE CONF
And then we'll have a PF X5 given its parents
and its parents are just X1 and X3.
NOTE CONF
All right, so this is the factorization.
Of a probability distribution.
NOTE CONF
From a graph.
And we also discussed last picture then.
NOTE CONF
What's interesting in these graphs is the absence of links,
right?
NOTE CONF
The absence of links, like an absence of a link
from X2 to X5 and X4 to X5, allows me
NOTE CONF
to write this probability not as PFX5 given X1 X2
X3X4, but now it's just PF X5 given X1 and
NOTE CONF
X3.
So the absence of links allows us to simplify these
NOTE CONF
probability distributions, all right.
But Great, uh, the question is what is the vector
NOTE CONF
representation here and how does it link to the probability.
So here I wrote PF X where X is a
NOTE CONF
vector with 5 random variables.
This will still output of probability which is a scalar,
NOTE CONF
uh, but this P of X, you can think of
it as just expanding it.
NOTE CONF
And so if X contains these 5 random variables, I'm
running the the joint probability of all 5 random variables
NOTE CONF
together.
Great question.
NOTE CONF
Other questions?
OK, so we're going to cover a few things with
NOTE CONF
these graphical models, uh, and then after that, we're I'm
going to apply it to diffusion.
NOTE CONF
So there are gonna be two questions we care about
with graphical models.
NOTE CONF
The first is independence.
Not spelled independence correctly in uh independence.
NOTE CONF
Um, If I have two random variables, A and B.
If they're independent, I use this symbol and that denotes
NOTE CONF
that A is independent of B.
In colloquial terms, when I ask a question, is A
NOTE CONF
independent of B?
The question that you should have in your mind is
NOTE CONF
There's knowing A Give me any additional information about B
that I didn't already know.
NOTE CONF
If it does, then A and B are not independent,
but if knowing A gives me no additional information about
NOTE CONF
B, then they are independent.
In mathematical terms, Independence is as follows.
NOTE CONF
If I write the joint probability of A and B.
This factorizes as P.
NOTE CONF
Of A times P of B.
This is equivalent to saying, right?
NOTE CONF
If I were to write out the chain rule of
PFAcom B that would equal PFA times PFB given A,
NOTE CONF
right?
And so this is equivalent to saying that PFB.
NOTE CONF
Given a equals PF.
Um, and the Chain Robert in the other direction also
NOTE CONF
holds so this would be PFA given B equals PFA,
right?
NOTE CONF
So that is independence.
Any questions there?
NOTE CONF
Should be refresher for everyone.
OK, and then we also have something called conditional independence.
NOTE CONF
This is gonna come up a lot in diffusion.
Additional independence.
NOTE CONF
Is written as the following.
Let's say I have 3 random variables A, B, and
NOTE CONF
C.
But then I observed the random variable C, so conditioned
NOTE CONF
on knowing the value of C.
R A and B independent.
NOTE CONF
So if A and B are independent, conditioned on me,
knowing the value of C, then A and B are
NOTE CONF
said to be conditionally independent.
The way that we mathematically write this is we take
NOTE CONF
the same independent statement, but we put a condition on
C for every single expression.
NOTE CONF
So this gives us P.
Of A B C.
NOTE CONF
Equals PFA given C.
Times PFB C.
NOTE CONF
All right.
And just like these statements here.
NOTE CONF
We have the equivalent thing for conditional independence.
I'm just gonna put a condition on C behind every
NOTE CONF
single uh probability expression.
And so this is the equivalent to saying.
NOTE CONF
That's uh P of B given C and A.
equals P B C.
NOTE CONF
And then PFA.
Given to C and B Equals PFA given C.
NOTE CONF
Right, so conditional independence.
Is The same expressions as independence except everything is now
NOTE CONF
conditioned on C.
All right.
NOTE CONF
Any questions there?
OK, so we're going to study two examples.
NOTE CONF
These will be the two examples that we'll encounter in
class of uh two simple graphs that that will show
NOTE CONF
us properties that we can generalize.
So the first example is this graph where we have
NOTE CONF
C.
And it's the parent of A and B.
NOTE CONF
That's example 1 and then example 2.
Will be uh this graph where A is the parent.
NOTE CONF
Of C, which is the parent of B.
Alright?
NOTE CONF
And then with all of with these two examples we're
going to seek to answer 3 questions.
NOTE CONF
The first question is.
What is The factorized.
NOTE CONF
Distribution Of all the variables of PF A, B, C,
that's going to be us applying.
NOTE CONF
This equation where we just do probability of each variable
given as parents.
NOTE CONF
And then we'll want to ask question number 2.
Is A independent of B.
NOTE CONF
And question number 3 is A.
Additionally independent of B given C.
NOTE CONF
All right, so we're gonna answer these three questions for
the two example graphs, and that's gonna help us a
NOTE CONF
lot for the diffusion derivation.
Questions here.
NOTE CONF
OK, let's move on then to the first example.
So we're going to take our first graph.
NOTE CONF
It has C as the parents of A and B.
And my first question is what is the factorized distribution
NOTE CONF
of P?
Of A, B, and C.
NOTE CONF
Someone raise your hand and tell me.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Great.
So it's probability of C times the probability of A
NOTE CONF
given C times the probability of B given C.
And we can read that right off the graph, so
NOTE CONF
that's correct because it's the probability of each node given
its parents.
NOTE CONF
Questions here?
OK, let's get to some more interesting questions then.
NOTE CONF
So the second question is, Is A independent of B.
Now, we can go ahead and just start to plug
NOTE CONF
in math to try to solve this, but before we
do that, I want us to have an intuitive answer.
NOTE CONF
So For the intuitive answer, then we ask this question.
If A It's independent of B.
NOTE CONF
And knowing A does not give me any information about
the random variable b.
NOTE CONF
That I did not already know, OK?
So intuitively are A and B independent.
NOTE CONF
Take 30 seconds to think about it, feel free to
talk to your neighbor.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna do a hand raising poll after that.
So intuitively are A and B independent.
NOTE CONF
All right.
I hear a lot of good discussion.
NOTE CONF
Let's do a hand raising poll.
Who here says, yes, A and B are independent?
NOTE CONF
Who here says no A and B are not independent.
OK, more people raise their hand for no, which is
NOTE CONF
the correct answer.
Intuitively, the answer is A and B are not independent.
NOTE CONF
Can someone who got this correct.
Give me an example or an intuition for why A
NOTE CONF
and B in this case are not independent.
7 Uh either is fine.
NOTE CONF
Great.
So, the answer that Kevin gave is If we're considering
NOTE CONF
that A, C, and B are binary variables, for example,
knowing A happened or not, knowing A equals 1 should
NOTE CONF
give me information on whether C happened or not, and
then knowing whether C happened or not should influence B.
NOTE CONF
And this is the general correct intuition.
So because of this graph structure.
NOTE CONF
A and C are linked, so knowing.
I'm gonna be a bit more general sort of binary.
NOTE CONF
I'm just gonna consider that A, B, and C are
continuous valued random variables.
NOTE CONF
Knowing the value of A is gonna give me some
information about the value of C.
NOTE CONF
And knowing the value of C because C is coupled
to B, C influences B, knowing the value of C
NOTE CONF
is gonna tell me some information about the value of
B.
NOTE CONF
OK, let me just actually write down an example so
that I'm not just saying these things vaguely.
NOTE CONF
Let's say that there was an actual model.
Let's say that A equals 5 times C plus noise.
NOTE CONF
OK, this is something that is a valid equation for
this link.
NOTE CONF
C is causal to A, so A is value is
going to be influenced by the value of C.
NOTE CONF
And then let's say that for this C to B
link we had another equation that B equals C+ noise.
NOTE CONF
So, in this example, Let's say that we got to
observe the value of A.
NOTE CONF
So if I observe the value of A, let's say
I have to observe that A equals 1, OK.
NOTE CONF
Then we're asking the question, does knowing the value of
A give me any information about B that I didn't
NOTE CONF
already know?
Well, from knowing A equals 1.
NOTE CONF
I can have a guess that C is probably in
the ballpark of what 0.2, right?
NOTE CONF
And then if C is in the ballpark of 0.2,
then B should also be in the ballpark of 0.2.
NOTE CONF
I say the ballpark because of these noise terms, right?
The noise terms means I'm not gonna get C exactly
NOTE CONF
or B exactly, but I'll be in the ballpark.
So I did get some more information that I expect
NOTE CONF
B to be around the value of 0.2.
Therefore, knowing A gave me information about B.
NOTE CONF
But I didn't already know and so they are dependent.
Questions there.
NOTE CONF
OK, so, if they're dependent, then I should not be
able to show the following.
NOTE CONF
So, PFAB.
If they were independent, this would factorize as PFA.
NOTE CONF
Times PFB.
But we should not be able to show that this
NOTE CONF
is true.
So let's go ahead and actually Do the derivation.
NOTE CONF
So I'll do it in purple.
PFAB, I want to simplify this probability given this graph,
NOTE CONF
OK.
If I want to do that, what should be?
NOTE CONF
A step that I take.
Uh, the one student says condition on C.
NOTE CONF
What do you mean by condition on C in this
case?
NOTE CONF
I introduce a term that conditions on C.
yeah, great.
NOTE CONF
So we want to introduce the term that conditions on
C.
NOTE CONF
I'll take that even more general step.
I need a Compute PFA B specifically for this graph.
NOTE CONF
All right.
What do I know about this graph?
NOTE CONF
I know that this graph factorizes according to this equation,
right?
NOTE CONF
And so I need it somewhere in my math simplify
that PF ABC equals this thing because that's what's specific
NOTE CONF
to this graph.
So how do I get a PF ABC into this
NOTE CONF
expression?
Uh Uh, the question is, uh, the answer is, can
NOTE CONF
I do PFA BC divided by PFC.
So in this case, PF ABC.
NOTE CONF
It's a good guess.
P ABC divided by PFC is equal to PFAB given
NOTE CONF
C, but here I have just PFA.
B, so I can't use my chain rule here.
NOTE CONF
How else can I introduce PF ABC into this expression?
Perfect.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
Sorry, can you remind me your name again?
NOTE CONF
Edward.
OK, so Edward says we can do a summation over
NOTE CONF
C.
So really, actually, let me just keep this here.
NOTE CONF
Remember when we manipulate probabilities, there are really two things
that will probably be The answer is either the chain
NOTE CONF
rule, which is what this is, or the law of
total probability, which is what Edward just said.
NOTE CONF
So we could do some over C.
Of PFA, B, and C.
NOTE CONF
And that's the correct approach here.
So what I'm going to now do is use Information
NOTE CONF
about this graph PF ABC equals PFC.
Times of a given C.
NOTE CONF
Time P of B given C.
And I want to see if I can simplify this
NOTE CONF
thing to equal P of A times P of B.
So the first thing that I'm going to do is
NOTE CONF
I'm just gonna try to get a P of A
out of here.
NOTE CONF
How can I get a PA out of this expression?
Yeah, you should.
NOTE CONF
Um, so, That I can I get, you get PFC
out by multiplying it by, are you talking about the
NOTE CONF
by multiplying PSC and PFA given C?
OK.
NOTE CONF
Consolidating some of these expressions here is on the correct
route.
NOTE CONF
If I told you to from this expression, extract out
of PFA, how would you do that?
NOTE CONF
Mhm.
Perfect.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, that's correct.
So, Answer is I can.
NOTE CONF
Take these two terms.
Remember my goal is to get out of PFA.
NOTE CONF
So if I multiply these two together, right?
I get PF A and C.
NOTE CONF
And then that multiplies P of B given C.
And then from my chain rule, I know that I
NOTE CONF
can decompose this as PFA times PFC given A, right?
And so this equals.
NOTE CONF
Some overse Of PFA Times PFC given A.
And then I have a times P of B given
NOTE CONF
C.
OK.
NOTE CONF
Now because PFA doesn't depend on C, I can bring
it out of the summation, and this equals.
NOTE CONF
You have a Times some over C.
Of P of C given A times P of B
NOTE CONF
given C.
All right?
NOTE CONF
And remember, if they were independent, I would be able
to simplify this to PFA times PB.
NOTE CONF
But what we should see is that in general, In
general, This Does not equal.
NOTE CONF
P B.
Right?
NOTE CONF
What are some cases in which this expression does actually
equal PFB?
NOTE CONF
Great, so one example where it does equal PFB is
if PFC given A equals PFC, right?
NOTE CONF
That's because then we have PFC times PFB given C,
which is PFB and C, and then I sum away
NOTE CONF
C so I only get PFB, right?
But PFC given A does not equal PFC because that
NOTE CONF
violates this graph.
This graph tells us that um the value of A
NOTE CONF
will give us information about C, all right?
And so.
NOTE CONF
That is uh one way that this could equal PFB,
but that is contradictory to the assumption of this graph.
NOTE CONF
So in general, because this thing does not equal PFB,
then we have shown that these are not independent.
NOTE CONF
Right?
Questions there.
NOTE CONF
OK, so that's answering question two is A independent of
B.
NOTE CONF
We're going to now do question three, which is um.
A and B conditionally independent given C.
NOTE CONF
So the way that we'll draw this for a graph
is as follows.
NOTE CONF
I'll have a graph.
The graph that we drew before.
NOTE CONF
And when I observe a variable when it's behind the
conditioning bar, what I'm going to do is I'm just
NOTE CONF
gonna highlight that graph.
I'm gonna shade it in with a color and that
NOTE CONF
tells me that the value of C is observed.
So C is no longer a random variable.
NOTE CONF
C has a single value that I observe, OK?
So the question is, are, A and B conditionally independent
NOTE CONF
given C, and I want us to answer this first
intuitively, and the intuitive question is to ask.
NOTE CONF
Does knowing a.
Sorry, A and B are conditionally independent given C if
NOTE CONF
knowing A.
Does not give me any more information about B than
NOTE CONF
what I already knew from knowing C, all right?
Take 30 seconds to think about that.
NOTE CONF
Feel free to talk to your neighbor and then we'll
do a hand raising poll again.
NOTE CONF
Alright, let's, let's do a hand raising.
Who says yes, A and B are conditionally independent given
NOTE CONF
C?
And then who says no, they are not conditionally independent
NOTE CONF
given sea.
All right, most people raise their hands for they are
NOTE CONF
conditionally independent given see.
And that is the correct answer.
NOTE CONF
So can someone who said yes to this give me
the intuition for why?
NOTE CONF
David Perfect.
Yeah, so David gives the right answer here, the correct
NOTE CONF
intuition, which is in our prior example, knowing A gave
me information about B through C, right?
NOTE CONF
That was our example here, but in the case where
I know C perfectly, knowing C perfectly already gives me
NOTE CONF
information about B.
If after knowing C perfectly, I get to observe A.
NOTE CONF
I don't get any more information about B because the
only way I could have would be that knowing A
NOTE CONF
tells me something about C, which then tells me something
about B, but I already knew C perfectly.
NOTE CONF
So I already knew.
Whatever I could about B from C.
NOTE CONF
Therefore, A didn't give me any additional information, so they're
conditionally independent.
NOTE CONF
Does anyone want me to repeat that?
All right, let's show it with math then.
NOTE CONF
So if we want to show conditional independence, we want
to show that PFA B given C.
NOTE CONF
Equals if a given C.
Times P B given C.
NOTE CONF
I want to see if this is true.
What's my first step?
NOTE CONF
Pain rule perfect.
And actually a student said it on the last slide
NOTE CONF
that's why I wrote it down.
PFAcom B given C equals PF ABC over PFC.
NOTE CONF
So this equals um P A B C.
Over PFC And then I'm gonna use then My factorized
NOTE CONF
distribution for the graph of ABC equals PFC.
Times PFA given C.
NOTE CONF
Times PB given C.
This is all divided by PFC.
NOTE CONF
And then you can see clearly these PFCs cancel and
I am therefore left with.
NOTE CONF
A given C times P B C.
Therefore, I can say that A.
NOTE CONF
And B are conditionally independent given C for this particular
graph.
NOTE CONF
All right.
Questions there.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
Uh, the question is, uh, does this matter that these
NOTE CONF
are directed graphs?
So for this class we will only do directed graphs
NOTE CONF
for undirected graphs, uh, we don't have, it's not clear
who is the parent and who is the child, and
NOTE CONF
so that requires a different formulation and so it is
important that these are directed.
NOTE CONF
Oh great, yeah, that's a good question.
So uh the question is if we reverse the arrows,
NOTE CONF
does it change the conditional independencies?
So in the next example, we're going to flip the
NOTE CONF
arrow between A and C, and we're going to see
that the, the same two answers that we got here
NOTE CONF
are the same or are the same, which is that
they are.
NOTE CONF
Not independent but they are conditionally independent.
But then there, there's gonna be a graph that I
NOTE CONF
don't do in this class.
I'll leave this as an exercise for you, but you
NOTE CONF
can have a graph where.
This is called the collider graph.
NOTE CONF
We're not going to do this, but I'll tell you
the answer.
NOTE CONF
You could have A and B both colliding on a
variable C.
NOTE CONF
And in this case A and B are independent, but
A and B are not conditionally independent given C and
NOTE CONF
so this has the opposite answer and so the arrow
directions do matter, and I'll leave that as an exercise
NOTE CONF
for you guys if you're curious to see the answer
come to my office hours.
NOTE CONF
So let's do the other one.
This is gonna be the graph that is really important
NOTE CONF
for diffusion and reinforcement learning.
Um, the first graph that we just did, example one,
NOTE CONF
that'll also be important for reinforcement learning, but for diffusion
we're really going to care about this graph.
NOTE CONF
So this is a graph that has A being the
parent of C, which is then the parent of B.
NOTE CONF
And the first question we want to ask is what
is the factorized distribution?
NOTE CONF
We can just do this by inspection.
PF ABC is PFA.
NOTE CONF
Times of parent, oh sorry, PFC parent, PFC given A
P of B given C.
NOTE CONF
All right.
Second question Is Uh R A and B.
NOTE CONF
Independent.
Intuitively The answer is no.
NOTE CONF
For the same reason that we had for the prior
graph.
NOTE CONF
If I know A, that gives me some information about
C.
NOTE CONF
Knowing C gives me some information about B.
So intuitively the answer here should be no.
NOTE CONF
And let's go ahead and do some um Probability here.
So if I want to write PFAcom B, we're gonna
NOTE CONF
do the exact same thing we did in the prior
example where we're going to use law of total probability
NOTE CONF
some over for C.
If A B C.
NOTE CONF
This will equal some over C.
We're gonna have PFA times PFC given A.
NOTE CONF
Times P of B given C.
Right.
NOTE CONF
I can factor out the PFA.
Or if not, I can pull it out of this
NOTE CONF
summation cause it doesn't depend on C, and I have
a sum over C.
NOTE CONF
Of PFC given A times P of B given C.
All right.
NOTE CONF
And just like in the prior example, at this point,
this term in general does not equal PFB and therefore
NOTE CONF
these two are not.
Independent.
NOTE CONF
So just like it's actually the exact same expression, um.
This expression in general.
NOTE CONF
This Does Not Equal P of B.
And so we can say that A and B are
NOTE CONF
not independent.
Questions there?
NOTE CONF
OK, and then let's do the other one.
Um, if I have the case that I have my
NOTE CONF
graph A C to B, and now I observe the
value of C.
NOTE CONF
We asked the question, are A and B conditionally independent
given C.
NOTE CONF
And the intuition for this one.
It's also the same as before.
NOTE CONF
A gives me information about C which gives me information
about B.
NOTE CONF
But if I observe C.
But I know its value.
NOTE CONF
And if I know it's value, that gives me already
a lot of information about the.
NOTE CONF
Knowing A will not give me any more information about
B because knowing A can only give me information about
NOTE CONF
B through C, and I know C perfectly already.
I got to observe it.
NOTE CONF
All right.
So, we'll write out the Formal math for this one.
NOTE CONF
If a comb given C.
Equals E of ABC divided by PFC.
NOTE CONF
This is the first step from For example one just
like before.
NOTE CONF
And then I'm going to plug in my factorized distribution
for PFABC.
NOTE CONF
So this equals E A P C A P of
B given C.
NOTE CONF
And then this is divided by.
E of C.
NOTE CONF
All right.
What should I do at this point to simplify this
NOTE CONF
expression?
Remember that my goal is to see does this thing
NOTE CONF
equal question mark PF A given C times PB given
C.
NOTE CONF
If it does, then they are conditionally independent, and they
should be because our intuition tells us they are conditionally
NOTE CONF
independent.
How do I simplify this expression to look like this?
NOTE CONF
Yes.
Perfect, yeah.
NOTE CONF
So we're going to use our chain rule for the
numerator.
NOTE CONF
I can uh combine, I'll write this down in two
steps just to be clear.
NOTE CONF
uh PFA times PFC given A equals PFA com C.
And PFB given C.
NOTE CONF
And then to cancel out this PFC in the denominator,
I can write my chain rule the other way.
NOTE CONF
So this will be PFC times PFA given C times
PFB given C.
NOTE CONF
Divided by PFC.
These PFCs now canceled out.
NOTE CONF
And I am left with.
BF A given C times P of B given C.
NOTE CONF
And therefore, we do have for this graph that A
is conditionally independent of the.
NOTE CONF
and see.
Right questions here.
NOTE CONF
OK, so I really want you to remember this graph
because what's going to happen in diffusion is we're going
NOTE CONF
to see several graphs that look like the following.
We're gonna have some variable X this could represent an
NOTE CONF
image at some time sub zero and.
I'm going to add noise to that to make it
NOTE CONF
X1.
I can add more noise to make it X2.
NOTE CONF
I can add more noise to make it X3 and
then eventually we turn it into gassian noise.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna call that X big T.
This is going to be common in our diffusion models
NOTE CONF
and what's gonna happen is I'm gonna want to write
some probability distributions.
NOTE CONF
Conditioned on others.
So maybe I want to write the distribution of X3
NOTE CONF
conditioned on knowing X2.
In this case, Right?
NOTE CONF
Um If I were to write this joint distribution, it
would be PF X0 times PX1 given X0 PX if
NOTE CONF
I didn't know if I didn't know this graph, if
I was just using the chain rule, I would have
NOTE CONF
the PF X2 given X1 and X0 PX3 given X2
X1 X0.
NOTE CONF
So using just a chain rule, I would have PX3
given X2 X1 X0.
NOTE CONF
But then the key thing is because This graph tells
me that x3.
NOTE CONF
Is conditionally independent of X1.
And actually not just X1 but anything to the left
NOTE CONF
of X1, given that I know X2, this probability here
simplifies to P of X3.
NOTE CONF
Given X2.
And this simplification is super important for All the derivations
NOTE CONF
we're going to do.
So basically in a diffusion model, if we observe a
NOTE CONF
variable like X2.
Then X3 will be conditionally independent of anything that comes
NOTE CONF
before X2.
Similarly, if I observe X3, then X4 is going to
NOTE CONF
be conditionally of any conditionally independent of anything that comes
before X3, all right?
NOTE CONF
And this is something that we call.
The Markov property.
NOTE CONF
What the Markov property tells me is if I If
I call time to the present time.
NOTE CONF
Then knowing.
By a random variable at the present time.
NOTE CONF
Is all I need to know to get the distribution
of the random variable the next time.
NOTE CONF
I don't need to know any history before X2.
All I need to know is X2.
NOTE CONF
Once I know X2, X1, and X0, I can throw
them away.
NOTE CONF
Kevin.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Great.
Uh, so, Kevin's question is, Uh, isn't PFX3 given X2
NOTE CONF
X1 X0 equal PFX3 given X2, a consequence of the
graph we constructed, i.e., like if we just write the
NOTE CONF
factorized distribution, we would have a PFX3 given X2 come
out, right?
NOTE CONF
And uh is there still a purpose of needing to
know this conditional independence property that X3 will be conditionally
NOTE CONF
independent of anything to the left of X2 given that
I know X2?
NOTE CONF
It will become useful because later on we will encounter
distributions like the following.
NOTE CONF
We're going to encounter uh a pea.
For example, of X3, given X2 X0.
NOTE CONF
And in this case, It's knowing the conditional independencies that
allow me to erase this X0.
NOTE CONF
Because I will know that X3 is conditionally independent of
anything before X2, given that I know X2.
NOTE CONF
So this thing will simplify also.
To give X3 Give an X.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, the, uh, Osy's question is, is the point that
if we change these two graphs together we can use
NOTE CONF
these simplifications to make conclusions.
The answer is yes.
NOTE CONF
So in diffusion we're only gonna have this graph, but
in reinforcement learning, we're gonna also have another arrow that
NOTE CONF
comes down, and that's gonna be our example one.
So both of those will will factorize our probability distributions
NOTE CONF
in a way that makes these problems tractable.
David.
NOTE CONF
Thank you, David.
It's because I made a typo.
NOTE CONF
That's a mistake.
Yeah, this is PFX3 given X2.
NOTE CONF
Thank you for that.
Other questions?
NOTE CONF
OK, remember, oh, Darren.
Uh, the question is what do I mean by observe
NOTE CONF
because if I had numbers in my model, wouldn't I
know what the numbers are?
NOTE CONF
So in this case we're just taking a very abstract
view.
NOTE CONF
C is a random variable, so maybe C takes on
values like 1234 or 5, and it takes them on
NOTE CONF
with some probability distribution.
In this case, when we say C is observed, then
NOTE CONF
we get to know the actual value that she takes
on like C equals 2 or C equals 4 rather
NOTE CONF
than C has this distribution of values 12345.
In the particular application of diffusion, these random variables are
NOTE CONF
going to actually be our corrupted images so they're going
to be noisy images and what the observation means is
NOTE CONF
I could see my corrupted image exactly as it is
at 3 at 3 for example.
NOTE CONF
So the observation means I get to actually view that
corrupted image at time 3.
NOTE CONF
Whereas if it wasn't observed, then I don't get to
know the exact pixels of the corrupted image.
NOTE CONF
I only get to know that I think it should
be corrupted by some amount.
NOTE CONF
It should have some noise statistics, but I don't actually
get to see the pixels of it.
NOTE CONF
Does that answer your question?
Perfect.
NOTE CONF
Other questions?
OK, we're gonna get to the derivation then.
NOTE CONF
So there's going to be a lot to cover.
We're gonna do it in the following order.
NOTE CONF
We're going to first derive denoising, diffusion probabilistic models.
When people think of like classical diffusion, this is what
NOTE CONF
it is, GDPM.
This is going to be a bunch of derivations, so
NOTE CONF
we're going to have to first derive how do we
add noise to an image to turn it into Gaussian
NOTE CONF
noise and how can I guarantee that it turns into
a unique Gaussian noise.
NOTE CONF
Then I'm going to have to make some model assumptions
to say how do we start to reverse this and
NOTE CONF
then I'm going to have to derive a loss function
because we have to always derive a loss function to
NOTE CONF
optimize and that loss function is going to be an
elbow.
NOTE CONF
In fact, the derivation of this elbow is gonna follow
the same steps of VAE initially, but then we're going
NOTE CONF
to see that there's going to be a lot more
uh math that we have to simplify.
NOTE CONF
All right.
After that, uh, derivation, then we're going to talk about
NOTE CONF
practical implementations of units and hyperparametters, then we'll talk about
conditional diffusion models, that's how you can, for example, say.
NOTE CONF
Braw me a picture of a white dog on grass
and it'll actually generate a picture of a white dog
NOTE CONF
on grass.
So the white dog on grass text will be the
NOTE CONF
condition that generates a particular um image.
Then we'll talk about some more efficient implementations of diffusion
NOTE CONF
including latent diffusion or it's also called stable diffusion.
We're gonna talk about ways that you can do diffusion
NOTE CONF
more quickly that's DDIM.
And then we'll talk about some cool applications of diffusion.
NOTE CONF
So this will probably take us to um Monday's lecture
on week 5, maybe even into Wednesdays, but that will
NOTE CONF
be how we follow the order of presenting diffusion.
All right.
NOTE CONF
We're about to go into the derivation and just like
Wasserstein Gans, it's easy to get lost in the weeds.
NOTE CONF
So let me first show you the overall algorithm so
you can see how simple it is and then we'll
NOTE CONF
show how we go from all this complex math to
this very simple algorithm.
NOTE CONF
So you know what, let me just start to zoom
in a bit.
NOTE CONF
That'll help since we don't have the big projector.
This is the algorithm for training a diffusion model.
NOTE CONF
This diffusion model is GDPM, so this is um In
the denoising.
NOTE CONF
Uh, diffusion Of ballistic models.
The training algorithm is as follows.
NOTE CONF
I have some X0 and X0 is my actual image.
So this is my image from a training set.
NOTE CONF
So maybe if I'm trying to generate CAR 10 images,
this is an image of a dog from a CAR10
NOTE CONF
training set.
Then I'm going to sample a time T, OK?
NOTE CONF
Um, T is gonna be between 1 and big T.
The intuition for this that we'll explain more rigorously later
NOTE CONF
is when T is equal to big T, this is
like this, uh, when, when little T equals big T,
NOTE CONF
your image is gonna be corrupted to full Gaussian noise.
When little T equals 1.
NOTE CONF
I have an image X1, and X1 is Barely corrupted.
I've only added a tiny bit of gasoline noise, so
NOTE CONF
the closer little T gets to big T, the more
noisy I've fallen in my for diffusion process.
NOTE CONF
Then I'm going to sample some noise Epsilon, which is
unitgassian.
NOTE CONF
And then I'm going to take a gradient descent up
on the following.
NOTE CONF
So this noise epsilon.
It's gonna be this epsilon here.
NOTE CONF
This epsilon is some noise that I've sampled.
And what I'm going to do is I'm going to
NOTE CONF
compare the squared error to this term.
OK, what is this term?
NOTE CONF
This epsilon data is a neural network.
That tries to predict the amount of noise Epsilon.
NOTE CONF
So this is.
Let me draw bigger.
NOTE CONF
This is a neural network with parameters data.
So this is my Neural network that tries to learn
NOTE CONF
the noise that add to images.
This neural network has two inputs.
NOTE CONF
The first is my time step T.
And that was what I sampled before because In my
NOTE CONF
neural network.
How I subtract noise depends on how far along the
NOTE CONF
diffusion process I am.
So if if little T equals big T, right?
NOTE CONF
I am at my pure Gaussian noise and the noise
I want to subtract there looks very different from if
NOTE CONF
little T equals 1, where I have a minimally corrupted
image and I just want to take out the little
NOTE CONF
bits of little specks of noise that are still on
it.
NOTE CONF
And then This is the other input.
And This you can think of as the corrupted image.
NOTE CONF
And so X0 is my image.
And this epsilon here is the noise that I sampled
NOTE CONF
and so depending on this value alphat with a bar
over it, if alphat with a bar over it is
NOTE CONF
close to 1, then this is going to be equal
to X0.
NOTE CONF
It's gonna be my perfectly fine image.
If alpha T bar equals 0, then this image here
NOTE CONF
is gonna be equal to 0, and then this contribution
is gonna be 1 minus 0, so it's gonna be
NOTE CONF
1 times epsilon.
So this is gonna be pure noise.
NOTE CONF
Then alpha T bar being somewhere in between is gonna
be those levels of noise uh for which I have
NOTE CONF
a partially noisy image, OK?
So our neural network is gonna take our partially noisy
NOTE CONF
image as well as the time along we are the
time that that we are along in the diffusion process.
NOTE CONF
And learn to predict the noise that you added, right?
If they can learn to predict the noise that you
NOTE CONF
added.
And what you can do is If you predicted that
NOTE CONF
noise accurately, you can subtract that noise away from your
image to make your image cleaner and cleaner.
NOTE CONF
Question.
Uh, the question is, uh, didn't quite catch what Q
NOTE CONF
represents online too.
Great.
NOTE CONF
So Q here is a distribution.
It's the distribution of natural images.
NOTE CONF
We can't write down what Q is, but Q of
X0 will be the distribution, so.
NOTE CONF
In practice, what this means is like what is your
data set?
NOTE CONF
So if Q is the distribution of CA 10 images,
and we're sampling a CA 10 image from our CAR10
NOTE CONF
data set.
We'll talk about these details further also.
NOTE CONF
You.
Yeah, the question is for the alpha T, do we
NOTE CONF
randomly initialize it and is it something that's learned, just
something that we update?
NOTE CONF
The answer is no, so alpha T will be a
hyperparameter.
NOTE CONF
So we set it at the beginning of the diffusion
and uh and we'll discuss exactly how we set that.
NOTE CONF
So I'll go into the details of where all of
these come around from.
NOTE CONF
Uh, yes, that's correct.
What is, what is your name?
NOTE CONF
Ian's question is, when I say we sample T, does
this mean like maybe the first iteration you sample T
NOTE CONF
equals 1, the next iteration you sample T equals 5,
maybe the next you sample T equals 500, uh, and
NOTE CONF
this just reflect how noisy the image is.
The answer is yes.
NOTE CONF
So basically this epsilon data, this neural network has to
learn to denoise the image for any time step.
NOTE CONF
And so this is my way of basically like sampling
a random time step to give it an example to
NOTE CONF
learn how to remove noise at that time.
Oh, great.
NOTE CONF
The question is, can I redescribe how I said when
alpha T.
NOTE CONF
Uh, is a value like 0.5 is a partially noisy
image, but when alpha T equals 0, it's a fully
NOTE CONF
noisy image.
So the some here reflects my noisy image.
NOTE CONF
I actually didn't finish writing this, so this is my
bad.
NOTE CONF
Um, So X0 is my clean image.
And Epsilon is noise.
NOTE CONF
So if alpha T bar equals 1, then I'm gonna
do X0 plus 0 so that's a fully clean image.
NOTE CONF
If alpha T equals 0.5, right, then I'm gonna have
some of my clean image but to it I'm also
NOTE CONF
gonna have added a lot of noise to it and
so this is a partially corrupted image and then if
NOTE CONF
alpha T equals 0, then I have no none of
my clean image and all noise and so um.
NOTE CONF
What What the actual noisiness of this image will be
will depend on the value of alphaar T.
NOTE CONF
Question, other questions?
Trust me.
NOTE CONF
Great.
The question is, do we decide capital T arbitrarily or
NOTE CONF
is that defined elsewhere?
We set the value of capital T.
NOTE CONF
Uh, it is arbitrary but we'll choose the judicious value
just as we'll also set the values of alpha T
NOTE CONF
as well.
Good question.
NOTE CONF
Other questions?
Yes.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the question is, uh, did I say that Epsilon
theta is computing the noise that we are subtracting, uh,
NOTE CONF
from our image to, uh, to bring it back to
the original image, uh.
NOTE CONF
So Epsilon theta is predict is trying to predict the
epsilon that we added to the noisy image.
NOTE CONF
So it's trying to predict basically this term, but just
this epsilon here.
NOTE CONF
So it's predicting the noise that we added to our
original image.
NOTE CONF
That's correct.
Other questions?
NOTE CONF
OK, then let me just say then after training, after
we learned the parameters data here, how does diffusion actually
NOTE CONF
work in real time or how does it actually work
to generate a new image?
NOTE CONF
So what we do is we start off with unit
Gaussian noise.
NOTE CONF
So X at time T.
Time T is when we've run our forward process so
NOTE CONF
far that we've turned our image into actual unit Gaussian
noise.
NOTE CONF
So what we do is when I want to generate
an image, I start off with my unit Gaussian noise.
NOTE CONF
And I do a 4 loop from big T to
1.
NOTE CONF
And at every single iteration, I sample some unique Gaussian
noise.
NOTE CONF
And then I compute this equation.
All right, we'll derive where this equation comes from, but
NOTE CONF
the key thing to see in this equation is what
you're saying is I'm going to take X of T.
NOTE CONF
And try to get to X of T minus 1.
Right, X of 0 is my image.
NOTE CONF
X of big T is my unit gassian noise.
So X of little T is noisier than X T
NOTE CONF
minus 1.
But if I can keep subtracting away noise, so if
NOTE CONF
I keep subtracting away noise, predicting noise from epsilon data,
my neural network, and hopefully I have moved XFT closer
NOTE CONF
to X of 0.
So I denoise XFT a bit by subtracting off the
NOTE CONF
predicted noise that gives me X of T minus 1.
Then I put XFT 1 into my neural network to
NOTE CONF
try to subtract off more noise that gives me XF
T minus 2 all the way down to X0.
NOTE CONF
All right, so that's a sampling operation of diffusion question.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
OK.
Yeah, this is really great.
NOTE CONF
So the question is, in the training algorithm, we can
add all the noise directly to X0.
NOTE CONF
So why is it that in the sampling operation, I
have to iteratively subtract the noise little by little, I,
NOTE CONF
I have to do a 4 loop that takes big
key time steps because if I could subtract all the
NOTE CONF
noise in one time step, then my inference would be
a lot faster.
NOTE CONF
I would remove a 4 loop.
This is a really great question.
NOTE CONF
So, Uh, the answer to the question will become a
lot clearer when we go to the derivations, but let
NOTE CONF
me give you the high-level answer right now, and if
you can't follow this, don't worry, we're gonna, it's gonna
NOTE CONF
make a lot more sense when we get to the
derivation, so.
NOTE CONF
Our 4 process is not challenging to parameterize, and it
is possible to actually write the distribution of any X
NOTE CONF
of T as a function of X of 0 and
the noise and so this is actually the correct parameterization
NOTE CONF
of the forward process in the reverse process, um, and
there's some intuition about that like we're just adding noise
NOTE CONF
to an image to make it look more like gas
gassian noise in the reverse process.
NOTE CONF
The noise that I subtract is going to depend on
that very particular image I'm looking at and it's gonna
NOTE CONF
depend on how noisy that image is and so.
For that reason, what happens is I have to take
NOTE CONF
that image and then specifically for that particular image, figure
out how to subtract off my noise to go back
NOTE CONF
one time set.
Now, there are ways to try to combine.
NOTE CONF
Um, ideas of Of subtracting greater noise.
And that's going to lead to some of the future
NOTE CONF
algorithms that we talked about, including DDIM where we can
basically.
NOTE CONF
Take this 4 loop and only do like every 10
or every 50 iterations, but that will require new ideas.
NOTE CONF
This will be clear when we actually do the math,
trust me.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the question is, when you say backwards, do you
mean from the noise to the image or from the
NOTE CONF
image to the noise?
Yeah, great.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so the question is, is there a correspondence between
Uh, an image and then some unique amount of gassian
NOTE CONF
noise.
The answer is in the end no, because you'll actually
NOTE CONF
notice the sampling process also has itself a noisy part
to it.
NOTE CONF
So even if you start off with the exact same.
Gaussian random noise observation on different runs of diffusion, you
NOTE CONF
will get different images.
David Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
Yeah, that's, yeah, David's question is when we return X0,
NOTE CONF
which is which is ideally an image from this distribution,
what can we expect?
NOTE CONF
So for this particular algorithm we can only expect the
sample from that distribution.
NOTE CONF
So if Q of X0 is my distribution of CA
10 images, I could expect an image that looks like
NOTE CONF
a CA 10 image.
And we're going to address this later on because we
NOTE CONF
know for image generation we give a prompt, right?
and they give us an image related to that prompt
NOTE CONF
and so that will, that will be where the condition
name comes in Edward.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
Great, uh, the question from Edward is if the intuition
NOTE CONF
is that we're trying to add, uh we're trying to
subtract noise repeatedly from the image to get my clean
NOTE CONF
image, why am I adding some noise back?
Hold that question, we may not even actually, we'll probably
NOTE CONF
get to it next lecture.
There are two answers here.
NOTE CONF
Uh, one is that it's actually just what is mathematically
correct.
NOTE CONF
So when we derive it, we're going to have a
variance term that this stigmat Z models.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the other though is that it will give you
some stochasticity in the trajectories, um, and that empirically seems
NOTE CONF
to also be a good thing.
Question Yeah, the question is, uh, is there a difference,
NOTE CONF
uh, in the quality of the image based off of
your initial sample and Uh, the answer should be yes.
NOTE CONF
It should suffer from this similar thing as Gan and
VAEs, which is that you rarely sample the outer parts.
NOTE CONF
However, um, Diffusion will be a lot more robust to
this because of this iterative subtraction and so even if
NOTE CONF
you have like a very outlier initial noise sample, uh,
as you subtract off noise, uh, these XFTs will hopefully
NOTE CONF
be more in distribution to what XFT should look like,
right?
NOTE CONF
Let's take a 5 minute break and when we come
back we'll start the derivation.
NOTE CONF
Any questions from the break?
The one thing I forgot to mention, uh, this alphaar
NOTE CONF
T is a function of T.
All right.
NOTE CONF
So it turns out that alphaar T We're gonna define
it shortly, but alphaar T.
NOTE CONF
Is a scaler.
That starts at 1 When T equals 0, And goes
NOTE CONF
to 0 when she goes to big T.
OK.
NOTE CONF
And so Alpha alphaar T is uh decreasing as little
T increases and so as little T increases my image
NOTE CONF
will become more and more corrupted.
OK.
NOTE CONF
Questions On any of the high-level algorithms.
Uh, the question is, does the bar have anything to
NOTE CONF
do with me yet, the bar will be for, uh,
for a geometric mean.
NOTE CONF
Other questions.
Is the question is, is there a difference between alpha
NOTE CONF
T with and without the bar?
Yeah, so, so, uh, I'll just say right now, alphaar
NOTE CONF
T is equal to the product of all the alpha
Ts.
NOTE CONF
So, uh, alphaar T will equal uh alpha 1 times
alpha 2 times alpha 3 all the way to alpha
NOTE CONF
T.
All right.
NOTE CONF
Other questions?
OK.
NOTE CONF
Um, And that actually, sorry, as I say that, I
shouldn't have a geometric meaning for you.
NOTE CONF
I should say it's the product of, it's the running
product of all the uh alpha I.
NOTE CONF
Other questions.
OK.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna dive into the details then.
Remember, we're gonna do a lot of math, but the
NOTE CONF
the algorithm is simple.
It's a squared loss for a neural network that predicts
NOTE CONF
noise.
And then when we want to generate an image, we
NOTE CONF
just keep subtracting away noise.
All right, um, it is super easy to lose the
NOTE CONF
force for the trees, and so here's our road map.
We're gonna start with the forward process.
NOTE CONF
The forward process tells us how to go from an
image to unit gassian noise.
NOTE CONF
So we're going to define that reverse, the forward process.
We need to define that because later on we're going
NOTE CONF
to reverse it, right?
After that, we're going to define our reverse process.
NOTE CONF
And then given this forward and reverse process, we're going
to derive a loss function, our elbow, OK?
NOTE CONF
That elbow is going to give us a loss that
allows us to optimize the neural network.
NOTE CONF
Then we're going to simplify our elbow because we're going
to see it's quite complicated and that elbow simplification is
NOTE CONF
actually going to eventually bring us to this nice easy
squared error loss.
NOTE CONF
OK.
Um, and then that will be the last function that
NOTE CONF
we can perform stochastic gradient descent on.
All right, so we'll start with the forward process.
NOTE CONF
In the forward process, our goal is to transform an
image which we're going to call X0.
NOTE CONF
So this is our image.
Into Gaussian noise, Z.
NOTE CONF
Z is also going to be written as X at
time T.
NOTE CONF
And X of time big T.
And Z, they're gonna be equal in distribution.
NOTE CONF
To a unit gas.
OK.
NOTE CONF
To do this, we're going to define an iterative process
in which we add noise repeatedly to our image and
NOTE CONF
so the graphical model.
For the 4 process books as follows.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna have X0.
Which is our image.
NOTE CONF
And to that we're going to add noise to get
X1.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna add more noise to get X2.
And this is gonna continue iteratively until.
NOTE CONF
We arrive at XT and XT should equal a unit
gassing and distribution, OK?
NOTE CONF
We know that this distribution is going to factorize as
the follows, um, it's gonna be the distribution of X0.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna call that Q of X0.
Times the distribution of X1 given X0, so that's gonna
NOTE CONF
be times Q.
Of X1 X0x Q of X2 X1.
NOTE CONF
All the way to Q of XT given X of
big T minus 1.
NOTE CONF
All right, so that's gonna be the factorized distribution of
this graph.
NOTE CONF
Q X0 is not something that we can optimize for.
Actually, none of this will have optimizable parameters, but Q
NOTE CONF
of X0 is the distribution of the images we're trying
to generate.
NOTE CONF
But then these Q of XTs given XT minus 1
like QX1 given X0, Q of X2 given X1.
NOTE CONF
What we will be able to do is to find
their distribution.
NOTE CONF
And show that for these definitions definitions of these conditional
distributions, when I add noise according to these distributions, X
NOTE CONF
of big T will turn into a unit Gaussian, all
right.
NOTE CONF
Questions here.
OK, so this here is the factorized density of the
NOTE CONF
graph that I just drew.
Uh, so this here is the math for what I
NOTE CONF
wrote down here.
OK.
NOTE CONF
So we need to define a density of XT given
XT minus 1 to run the forward process and really
NOTE CONF
the constraint of this distribution is that it has to
be so that when I apply this distribution, when I
NOTE CONF
apply this forward process I get Gaussian noise that's unit
Gaussian noise at the end.
NOTE CONF
All right.
So We are going to define the four process as
NOTE CONF
follows.
um.
NOTE CONF
We're first going to define a hyperparameter beta T.
Beta T is going to be between 0 to 1.
NOTE CONF
4 T equals 1 all the way to big T.
Remember, big T is the end of our 4 process
NOTE CONF
where we hope we have Gaussian noise at, OK?
We get to choose whatever distribution we want, and there
NOTE CONF
are many ways to take an image and turn it
into unit gassian noise.
NOTE CONF
We are going to do it this way, OK?
So I'm going to pull this distribution out of the
NOTE CONF
air, but we're going to see why it works.
So I'm going to define Q of XT given XT
NOTE CONF
minus 1.
As a normal distribution.
NOTE CONF
With this mean And this covariance.
All right.
NOTE CONF
OK, again, I admit to you right now it looks
like this came out of nowhere.
NOTE CONF
So let's try to unpack this and understand and see
if indeed this forward process takes us to Gaussian noise
NOTE CONF
as T goes to infinity, OK.
My first question for you.
NOTE CONF
is the following.
When I look at this equation, when I look at
NOTE CONF
this distribution.
What it's telling me is, given I know XF T
NOTE CONF
minus 1, so XF T minus 1 is gonna be
some noisy image that I see.
NOTE CONF
I am building or I am defining a distribution over
what XFT is.
NOTE CONF
So XFT is gonna be a noisier image at the
next time step, OK?
NOTE CONF
It's gonna be a Gaussian or a normal distribution.
We know That's, if I take A noisy signal that's
NOTE CONF
Gaussian.
So let's say X of T minus 1 is Gaussian.
NOTE CONF
If I apply just an affine transformation to it.
And XFT will also be Gaussian.
NOTE CONF
So this distribution that I'm writing here, it can be
written in a simpler way where X of T.
NOTE CONF
It's gonna be some function.
Of X of T minus 1.
NOTE CONF
It's actually that there is also going to be an
affine function.
NOTE CONF
So I want you to take 30 seconds to a
minute to think about how I can write an affine
NOTE CONF
equation.
Such that X of T equals some affine transformation of
NOTE CONF
XT minus 1 as well as some noise epsilon that
is unit gassian.
NOTE CONF
Such that XFT.
Given I have observed X of T minus 1 is
NOTE CONF
gonna have this distribution.
All right.
NOTE CONF
So basically what I'm saying is think a bit for
30 seconds, feel free to talk to your neighbor about
NOTE CONF
how to transform this distribution here.
Into an actual affine equation and then we'll ask someone
NOTE CONF
to get the answers.
All right, I hear some good conversation.
NOTE CONF
I should have prefaced this by saying if you've never
done this before, this is a very challenging question, uh,
NOTE CONF
but hopefully when we see the answer you'll see it
all makes sense.
NOTE CONF
So does anyone have the equation of how XFT is
a function of X of T minus 1 that implements
NOTE CONF
this distribution?
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Perfect, that's the correct answer.
OK, so this is the Correct answer for.
NOTE CONF
The affine equation That Reflects this conditional distribution, right?
How do we actually show that this is true?
NOTE CONF
After we show this once, you should be able to
do this basically by inspection.
NOTE CONF
And so, Remember first that any affine transformation of the
Gaussian distribution is Gaussian.
NOTE CONF
We showed that in the VAE lecture, right?
When I have a Gaussian distribution, Once I know it's
NOTE CONF
mean and it's covariant, I know the entire distribution.
So I never have to do, you know, complicated.
NOTE CONF
Derivations of matching probability distributions.
If I want to know what the distribution of XT
NOTE CONF
given XT minus 1 is, all I have to do
is calculate what the mean of XT given XT minus
NOTE CONF
1 is, what the covariance is.
Since I know the distribution is Gaussian, the conditional mean
NOTE CONF
and the conditional covariance will describe the entire distribution.
Let me write this out and it'll become easier.
NOTE CONF
So let's start off with the conditional means.
So this is a distribution.
NOTE CONF
Q of XT given XT minus 1, it's going to
be a normal distribution with some mean.
NOTE CONF
The mean I'm gonna call the expected value.
Of XT given XT minus 1.
NOTE CONF
And it's gonna have some covariants.
The covariance I'm going to write as the covariance of
NOTE CONF
X of T given X of T minus 1.
All right.
NOTE CONF
So let's go ahead and just try to compute what
expected value of XT given XT minus 1 is for
NOTE CONF
this equation.
So if I want to compute the expected value.
NOTE CONF
Of X of T Given X of T minus 1.
What I'm going to first do is I'm gonna plug
NOTE CONF
in that X of T equals this equation right here,
OK.
NOTE CONF
So this is equal to the expectation.
Of square root of 1 minus beta T.
NOTE CONF
Times X of T minus 1.
Since the expectation is linear, I'm gonna separate this into
NOTE CONF
two expectations right now, so I'll have my first term.
This is conditioned on X of T minus 1.
NOTE CONF
And then I have a plus, the expectation.
Of square root of beta T.
NOTE CONF
Times Epsilon.
Given that I know X of T minus 1.
NOTE CONF
All right.
Let's just consider this term.
NOTE CONF
What is this term equal to?
Someone other than you to give me the answer, but
NOTE CONF
what is your name?
Neil, someone other than a meal because he knows he
NOTE CONF
gave us the answer.
What is this first expectation equal to?
NOTE CONF
Great, it's constant, right?
The answer is yes.
NOTE CONF
What is a constant?
Yeah, take the E.
NOTE CONF
So what is the expectation say?
The expectation says find me the average value of a
NOTE CONF
random variable, but things that are not random come out
of the expectation.
NOTE CONF
Beta T is something that I defined beforehand.
It's not random.
NOTE CONF
It has some value like 0.1 or 0.2.
X of T minus 1 is normally random.
NOTE CONF
What?
I have observed it, right?
NOTE CONF
So this is conditioned on knowing what X of T
minus 1 is.
NOTE CONF
Once I condition on knowing what X of T minus
1 is, X of T minus 1 is no longer
NOTE CONF
random.
So nothing in this expression is random.
NOTE CONF
Therefore, since this is a value, this is some vector,
but if X of T minus 1 was a scalar,
NOTE CONF
this would be some value like 5.7.
I'm saying what is the expected value of 5.7?
NOTE CONF
It's 5.7.
It has no randomness.
NOTE CONF
So the expected value of this expression is equal.
To just the value of the expression because it's not
NOTE CONF
random at all.
1 minus beta T times X of T minus 1.
NOTE CONF
What's the expected value of this expression?
0, yeah.
NOTE CONF
How do we know that square root of beta T
has some value.
NOTE CONF
It can come outside the expectation.
Then we're taking the expected value of some noise that
NOTE CONF
has zero mean, given that I know some image.
This image doesn't affect this noise at all.
NOTE CONF
This noise is independent, and so this noise will always
have zero mean, and so this has zero mean.
NOTE CONF
So I do a plus 0, and this tells me
then if this is my equation relating XF T minus
NOTE CONF
1 to XFT.
Then the conditional mean E of XT given XT minus
NOTE CONF
1 is square root of 1 minus beta T X
T minus 1.
NOTE CONF
That's exactly what this expression is.
So I've matched the means, OK.
NOTE CONF
Now I want to match the covariances.
So For that, I'm going to compute the covariance.
NOTE CONF
Of XFT, given X of T minus 1.
OK.
NOTE CONF
Here, um Since These two are independent.
I can write this as the covariances since the noise
NOTE CONF
epsilon is independent of the image X of T minus
1.
NOTE CONF
I can write this as I'll just write this as
the covariance of this first term.
NOTE CONF
Uh But this first term We already know if you
observe X of T minus 1 has no randomness.
NOTE CONF
Actually, let me, let me write this down.
This will be covariance.
NOTE CONF
Of square root of 1 minus beta T.
Times XT minus 1, given XT minus 1.
NOTE CONF
Plus covariants of square root of beta T.
Epsilon, given X of T minus 1.
NOTE CONF
So just like for this red example, if I know
what X of T minus 1 is, X of T
NOTE CONF
minus 1 is deterministic and so is 1 minus beta
T.
NOTE CONF
So this is just a number like 5.7.
What's the covariance of a number that is not random,
NOTE CONF
it's 0.
So this first covariance term equals 0.
NOTE CONF
And for the second term, Again, epsilon and X of
T minus 1 are independent, so this is really just
NOTE CONF
the covariance of the square root of beta T times
epsilon.
NOTE CONF
Right, we know that when you multiply by a constant,
the covariance is going to be that constant squared.
NOTE CONF
Times the covariance of epsilon.
The constant squared is equal to beta T.
NOTE CONF
And then the covariance of epsilon equals the identity matrix,
right?
NOTE CONF
So the covariance of XFT given XFT minus 1 is
beta T times I.
NOTE CONF
And therefore I've matched the covariances.
Therefore, Again, because we knew that this was already gassing
NOTE CONF
distribution and it's defined by its mean and its covariance.
I've shown that this blue affine equation.
NOTE CONF
I The correct.
Affine equation that represents this property distribution, where if I
NOTE CONF
want to know.
The distribution of XT Given that I've observed X of
NOTE CONF
T minus 1.
This equation here Well actually compute me a sample from
NOTE CONF
that distribution.
All right.
NOTE CONF
Questions here.
You raise your hand if you're following.
NOTE CONF
OK, great.
That's most of the class.
NOTE CONF
All right.
So, Given that that is our equation, If we can
NOTE CONF
simplify this equation, Then this will allow us to see
what this X of little T look like as big
NOTE CONF
T goes to infinity.
Does this actually go to a unique gassian distribution.
NOTE CONF
So what we're going to do is we're going to
do some simplification and I have a typo here, there
NOTE CONF
should be a square root.
Beta T over here.
NOTE CONF
This is the equation from the prior slide that Emil
gave us.
NOTE CONF
All right.
Now we're going to define alpha T.
NOTE CONF
So alpha T equals 1 minus beta T.
All right.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna do that so that instead of a 1
minus beta T here I have an alpha T.
NOTE CONF
and then we're going to define alphaar T and that's
the running product of the alpha Is from I equals
NOTE CONF
1 to T, OK.
Um, in this proof, I'm going to index the epsilons
NOTE CONF
with A subscript key, but The epsilons are IID.
They're independent and identically distributed for all T.
NOTE CONF
So every epsilon T is gonna just be a unique
Gaussian random variable for all T, and they're going to
NOTE CONF
be independent from each other.
We're just gonna do this for the sake of being
NOTE CONF
able to write this out cleanly, OK.
So What I want to do in this reparameterization is
NOTE CONF
I'm going to want to write XFT as a function
of X0.
NOTE CONF
Right?
This is gonna be useful because what this tells us
NOTE CONF
is if I want to know my corrupted image at
time XFT.
NOTE CONF
I can just apply one equation.
To my initial image x of 0.
NOTE CONF
Rather than having to do a 4 loop, adding noise
iteratively from each time, and this is called the reparameterization
NOTE CONF
of the 4 process.
This reparameterization allows us to in our algorithm that we
NOTE CONF
saw here.
Add noise directly to X of 0 to get X
NOTE CONF
of T.
All right, so this is The first part of the
NOTE CONF
answer to Kevin's earlier question, which is, uh, how can
we write this as like basically just one step of
NOTE CONF
adding noise to X of 0, we're going to derive
that right now.
NOTE CONF
And that means that we don't have to do a
for loop for the forward process.
NOTE CONF
So, what I'm going to do, let me zoom in
a bit so that it is easier to see.
NOTE CONF
I, I'm going to write.
This equation and I'm going to try to write it
NOTE CONF
as a function of X0.
How am I going to do that?
NOTE CONF
This function is right now.
XFT is now a function of X of T minus
NOTE CONF
1.
I'm going to plug in X of T minus 2
NOTE CONF
and see what happens.
All right.
NOTE CONF
So, Um, X of T equals.
So actually, first I'm going to Do my substitution of
NOTE CONF
alpha t equals 1 minus beta T, so that's going
to give me X T equals square root of alpha
NOTE CONF
T.
Times X of T minus 1.
NOTE CONF
Plus Square root of 1 minus alpha T.
Epsilon and I'm gonna put a T minus 1 here.
NOTE CONF
But again, remember all the epsilonte's have a unit gassian
distribution.
NOTE CONF
OK.
What I'm next going to do is I'm going to
NOTE CONF
plug in.
That X of T minus 1.
NOTE CONF
It's going to be square root of 1 minus beta
T X T minus 2 plus square, it's going to
NOTE CONF
be equal to square root of 1 minus beta T
minus 1 times X of T minus 2 plus square
NOTE CONF
root of beta T minus 1 times X1.
So basically I'm just changing all the Ts here to
NOTE CONF
T minus 1.
And that gives me this equation.
NOTE CONF
So 1 minus beta T minus 1 is alpha T
minus 1, so I'm gonna have a square root of
NOTE CONF
alpha T minus 1.
X of T minus 2.
NOTE CONF
Square root of 1 minus alpha T minus 1.
Times epsilon of T minus 2.
NOTE CONF
And this is plus square root of 1 minus alpha
T.
NOTE CONF
Epsilon T minus 1.
OK.
NOTE CONF
Any questions there?
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Great.
The question is how did the epsilon from the first
NOTE CONF
line turn to epsilon T minus 1.
so I just decided in these lines to assign a
NOTE CONF
subscript to it just so that you could differentiate this
epsilon from this epsilon.
NOTE CONF
But these are all the same epsilon or not, they're
not the same exact epsilon.
NOTE CONF
They have the same distribution as epsilon.
So all these epsilontes are going to be unit gassian,
NOTE CONF
but they're going to be independent.
I've only now assigned the subscript so you can see
NOTE CONF
that they have a different epsilons here, that these are
different epsilons.
NOTE CONF
These are not the same exact epsilon.
At this point I'm also just going to remove this
NOTE CONF
parenthesis, actually I'll write it out.
I'm just going to do a distribution, so I'm going
NOTE CONF
to Distribution of the square root alpha T, so square
alpha T um Times Alpha T minus 1.
NOTE CONF
X T minus 2.
And then I'm going to have plus.
NOTE CONF
Square root of alpha T.
Times square root of 1 minus alpha T minus 1,
NOTE CONF
epsilon T minus 2, plus square root of 1 minus
alpha T epsilon T minus 1.
NOTE CONF
OK.
Any questions here?
NOTE CONF
OK, I'm now going to take these two terms.
Which are Failed versions of unit Gaussian noise and combine
NOTE CONF
them and I know that the output is going to
be Gaussian because affine transformations of Gaussian random vectors are
NOTE CONF
still Gaussian.
So because they are going to be the sum of
NOTE CONF
these two Gaussian random vectors are going to be Gaussian,
to know the distribution of the sum of these two,
NOTE CONF
all I have to do is compute their mean and
their covariant just like we did before on the prior
NOTE CONF
slide.
So I want to combine.
NOTE CONF
These two noise terms.
And I know they're gonna be Gaussian distributed.
NOTE CONF
But then their meaning their covariances, I'm gonna have to
compute.
NOTE CONF
Right?
What is the meaning of the sum of these two?
NOTE CONF
Noise variables, scale noise variables.
0, great, yeah.
NOTE CONF
This has 0 mean and this has 0 means, so
the mean is 0.
NOTE CONF
All right.
What is the covariance?
NOTE CONF
Uh Right.
So, uh, yeah, let's do it turn by turn.
NOTE CONF
So for epsilon T minus 2, its covariance is going
to be whatever it multiplies squared.
NOTE CONF
So that's going to be alpha T times 1 minus
alpha, T minus 1.
NOTE CONF
Times the covariance of epsilon T minus 2, which is
identity.
NOTE CONF
So I have times identity here.
And then for this expression, I'm going to have whatever
NOTE CONF
scales squared, so it's going to be 1 minus alphat.
Time the covariance of epsilon T minus 1, which is
NOTE CONF
identity.
Right.
NOTE CONF
Questions there?
Let's just do some algebra then.
NOTE CONF
So I'm going to simplify this.
This equals the normal distribution with mean zero.
NOTE CONF
I'll have an alpha T minus alpha T, alpha T
minus 1.
NOTE CONF
Plus 1 minus alpha T, all of this multiplying.
The identity matrix.
NOTE CONF
And from here we can see that this simplifies the
alpha Ts will cancel out and so and so I'm
NOTE CONF
going to get a 1 minus alpha alpha T minus
1.
NOTE CONF
Just to save space, I'm going to just write that
here.
NOTE CONF
1 minus alpha T, alpha T minus 1.
Gonna be one Minus alpha T, Alpha T minus 1.
NOTE CONF
And the identity.
OK.
NOTE CONF
And what that means is that I can rewrite this
equation here.
NOTE CONF
As equal to The square root of um alpha T.
Alpha T minus 1 times X of T minus 2,
NOTE CONF
plus The square root Of 1 minus alpha T times
alpha T minus 1 times epsilon.
NOTE CONF
Right?
Because this term is going to have zero mean and
NOTE CONF
its covariance is going to be this covariance matrix.
Questions here.
NOTE CONF
OK, if no questions, then what I want you to
see is now I've written XFT in terms of X
NOTE CONF
of T minus 2.
And what changes is that instead of just an alpha
NOTE CONF
T here, I have an alpha T times alpha T
minus 1, instead of a 1 minus alpha T here,
NOTE CONF
I have a 1 minus alpha T times alpha T
minus 1.
NOTE CONF
If you now plug in X of T minus 2
as a function of X of T minus 3 here,
NOTE CONF
you'll further simplify uh all the way down to X0.
I'm going to skip all those steps because We already
NOTE CONF
see a pattern The pattern is if I go all
the way down to X of 0, I'm going to
NOTE CONF
have alpha T times alpha T minus 1 times alpha
T minus 2 all the way down to alpha 1.
NOTE CONF
And so the product of all of the alphas up
to alpha T is going to be alphaar T.
NOTE CONF
So this is going to change into alphaar T times
X0 plus square root of 1 minus and then this
NOTE CONF
is going to be the same thing.
I'm gonna have alpha T, alpha T minus 1 all
NOTE CONF
the way down to alpha 1 multiplying each other.
So that's going to give me 1 minus alphaar T.
NOTE CONF
I'ms Epsilon.
OK.
NOTE CONF
So this is writing XFT in terms of X0.
Questions there.
NOTE CONF
OK, so then here's my question for you.
If I were to tell you to write me the
NOTE CONF
distribution, Q of XT given X0, right, we're gonna go
in the reverse direction now.
NOTE CONF
We're going to go from an affine equation to a
distribution.
NOTE CONF
The first thing that I'm going to note is X
of T given X0 is going to be an affine
NOTE CONF
distribution as it's gonna be, it's gonna be a normal
distribution because it's an affine transformation of Gaussian random vectors.
NOTE CONF
So it's gonna be normally distributed but with some mean
and some covariants.
NOTE CONF
So what is the mean?
Given this equation.
NOTE CONF
So, uh, you're correct.
This is a zero mean here for this first term,
NOTE CONF
remember X0 is observed.
So X0 is no longer zero mean X0 will have
NOTE CONF
some values and so this will be a constant and
this will be another constant and so together these two
NOTE CONF
multiplying each other will become the mean.
So the mean here is gonna be.
NOTE CONF
The square root Of alpha T X 0.
Again, that's because this expression is conditioned on X0, so
NOTE CONF
X0 is no longer random.
X0 is gonna be some image.
NOTE CONF
That has some value like 5.7, 6.3, etc.
It's not random at all, so this contributes to the
NOTE CONF
name.
What is the covariance of the distribution of X of
NOTE CONF
T given X of 0?
Perfect.
NOTE CONF
It's 1 minus alphaar T.
Is the identity.
NOTE CONF
Right, the reason that we know that is we can
take the covariance of this expression.
NOTE CONF
Given X0.
Given x0, this term is not random.
NOTE CONF
So the only term that contributes something random is this
term.
NOTE CONF
And this covariance is going to be this thing squared
times the covariance of epsilon, which is 1 minus alphaar
NOTE CONF
T times identity.
All right.
NOTE CONF
And then what you should also see is from this
equation here we've derived one element of training.
NOTE CONF
So back in This slide right here, we said that
the corrupted image was going to be the square root
NOTE CONF
of alpha T times X0 plus square root of 1
minus alphaar T times epsilon and this equation here is
NOTE CONF
exactly what we've just arrived.
Over here.
NOTE CONF
Right, so this takes my perfect image X of 0
and maps it to a corrupt image at time X
NOTE CONF
of T to just a single transformation where if I
apply this equation, I get X of T.
NOTE CONF
All right.
Questions here.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
Great.
NOTE CONF
The question is, is beta T just an arbitrary sequence
of numbers here?
NOTE CONF
That's the perfect transition to the next slide.
So, uh, how do you choose beta T?
NOTE CONF
So in the GDPM paper, beta T was chosen in
the following way.
NOTE CONF
If I have time.
So the X-axis is little T and it goes from
NOTE CONF
0 to big T and beta T here.
It's going from 0 to 1.
NOTE CONF
The prior.
But the GDPM paper just defined beta T as follows.
NOTE CONF
The line that goes up.
And so, Um, Make big tea over here.
NOTE CONF
OK.
And that choice of beta T, that hyperparameter choice of
NOTE CONF
beta T works.
There have been later works that have come on, and
NOTE CONF
what they have done is They have used this intuition
as follows at time T equals 0, maybe I want
NOTE CONF
to be a bit more careful in adding noise because
that's my perfect image, right?
NOTE CONF
But at later time steps, right, when my noise, my
image is already mostly noise, I can add more epsilon.
NOTE CONF
I can increase beta even more.
So frequently these days when you schedule beta T, it'll
NOTE CONF
actually maybe look a bit like this.
One way that you can implement this is via what
NOTE CONF
is called cosine annealing and so when beta T is
linear like this, if you compute alphaar T, you get
NOTE CONF
this blue line here, but if you choose, um, if
you choose beta T to look more like this, then
NOTE CONF
you get this cosine annealing and so alphaar T will
start off higher and then and then go down, uh,
NOTE CONF
more gracefully again this reflects that maybe you want to
not add that much noise at the early time steps.
NOTE CONF
And then in the later time steps when your image
is already almost towards gasing noise, you can up the
NOTE CONF
noise that you add.
You're adding more noise to something that already looks noisy,
NOTE CONF
OK?
And this orange line tends to have better empirical performance.
NOTE CONF
Today there are even more fancy ways to uh do
your scheduling including different re reparameterizations into like velocity vectors
NOTE CONF
and whatnot.
We won't cover those in this class, but uh in
NOTE CONF
this class uh we'll cover this linear and this cosine
and kneeling.
NOTE CONF
Questions here.
OK.
NOTE CONF
The other thing I want you to then see.
Is that As Big T goes to infinity.
NOTE CONF
What does this distribution turn into?
What you should see is as big T goes to
NOTE CONF
infinity, right, Alphaar T.
Eventually goes to zero and so it's going to be
NOTE CONF
0 times X0.
That's gonna be 0 mean and it's gonna be 1
NOTE CONF
minus 0 times identity and that's just equal to identity.
So as big T goes to infinity, we in fact
NOTE CONF
do see that we've done what we want to in
the forward process, which is as T goes to infinity,
NOTE CONF
I turn X of big T into a unit gassian
distribution.
NOTE CONF
Right?
And so this is also the proof that when I
NOTE CONF
chose this equation for how I'm going to iteratively add
noise to every image.
NOTE CONF
I was able to turn that image into pure Gaussian
noise, and then we also have this added benefit.
NOTE CONF
I don't have to do this thing iteratively.
You could just tell me what time step T I
NOTE CONF
want you to generate a noisy image for.
Give me my clean image, and if I just apply
NOTE CONF
this equation, that will give me my noisy image at
time T.
NOTE CONF
Right, that's a lot of questions here.
Yeah, Oh yeah, great question is, uh, I skipped a
NOTE CONF
few steps in going from X T minus 2 to
X0.
NOTE CONF
How did I do that?
So, um, you could, so If you recursively follow this
NOTE CONF
down all the way down to X0, then you'll get
this equation.
NOTE CONF
What I didn't do is I didn't show like you
could do a square root of alpha T.
NOTE CONF
Alpha T minus 1 and then for X of T
minus 2, plug in square root of alpha T minus
NOTE CONF
2 times X of T minus 3 plus square root
of 1 minus alpha T minus 2.
NOTE CONF
Uh, epsilon T minus 3 plus.
And so if you keep following this recursively down, then
NOTE CONF
you eventually get this equation over here.
Thanks for that clarifying question.
NOTE CONF
Other questions.
All right.
NOTE CONF
And that is the forward process and that tells us
then how we add.
NOTE CONF
Noise to an image.
To progressively turn it into a unit gassian distribution.
NOTE CONF
All right.
That's actually the quote unquote easy part of diffusion.
NOTE CONF
Let me make sure the projector comes back on.
Are there any questions on this board process?
NOTE CONF
OK, let's get to the harder thing then, which is,
once we've defined this forward process.
NOTE CONF
How can I actually go ahead?
And reverse it.
NOTE CONF
So the first thing that we need to do is
we need to define a reverse process, right?
NOTE CONF
So we've done #1 the forward process.
Now we're doing number 2, define the reverse process.
NOTE CONF
This is actually just going to be a single slide
because this is going to be an assumption that we
NOTE CONF
make on our model.
And After that, given the assumption that we made, given
NOTE CONF
the distribution that we choose, we're going to divide the
elbow.
NOTE CONF
OK, so first, the reverse process, how are we going
to define it?
NOTE CONF
We're gonna define it as follows.
I'm gonna draw the graph of the reverse process.
NOTE CONF
What happens in the reverse process is that we start
off.
NOTE CONF
From our unit gassian noise.
So X of big T is my unique gassian noise.
NOTE CONF
Into it I am going to start to.
Subtract away noise.
NOTE CONF
According to some distribution.
Some uh equation.
NOTE CONF
That eventually is gonna take me.
Back to my perfect image, or sorry, an image from
NOTE CONF
my distribution X0.
OK.
NOTE CONF
We know that this graph factorizes as follows.
It's going to be PF X for big T.
NOTE CONF
Times of X, so big T minus 1 given X
of big T.
NOTE CONF
Times P of X.
The big T minus 2 given X the big T
NOTE CONF
minus 1.
And what that means is that if I want to
NOTE CONF
parameterize.
This reverse diffusion process.
NOTE CONF
I need to be able to write down what these
distributions are.
NOTE CONF
All right.
So PFXT we already know PFX big T, that's my
NOTE CONF
unit gassian distribution.
But I need to know, or I need to assume
NOTE CONF
a form of PF X T minus 1 given X
of big T or PF X of big T minus
NOTE CONF
2 given X of big T.
In general, I need to parameterize this this distribution P
NOTE CONF
of little XT minus X T minus 1 given X
of little T, OK.
NOTE CONF
I'm just going to tell you the answer for what
we select, and I'll give you three reasons why it's
NOTE CONF
reasonable.
So we need to be able to write this as
NOTE CONF
some density, and I'm just going to choose it to
be a unit, a Gaussian distribution where the mean and
NOTE CONF
the covariance are parameterized by neural networks.
So this should look very similar to the VAE, right?
NOTE CONF
So what I'm saying is if I want to go
from a noisier image XFT to a less noisy image
NOTE CONF
X of T minus 1.
I'm going to pass my image XFT into two into
NOTE CONF
two neural networks.
Those two neural networks will return to me the distribution
NOTE CONF
mean and the distribution covariance of X of T minus
1.
NOTE CONF
And then from there I could sample an X of
T minus 1.
NOTE CONF
All right.
Why did I choose to be a normal distribution?
NOTE CONF
So first, Normal distribution is easy to work with.
We've seen that for all of our generative models.
NOTE CONF
People like to choose normal distribution.
So that's reason number one.
NOTE CONF
Reason number 2 is In my forward process, my Q
of XTs given XT minus 1s were also Gaussian.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna have expressions that have both the Q's and
the P's and the cues are already Gaussian, so if
NOTE CONF
I choose the pieces to be Gaussian, I'll match the
distributions and we'll have some, uh some niceDs from there.
NOTE CONF
OK, the third reason is the more fundamental reason that
I'm going to say it's beyond the scope of this
NOTE CONF
course, but if you're interested in it, uh, you should
take a stochastic processes course.
NOTE CONF
So, Um, if you try to reverse a stochastic process,
like, for example, Browning in motion.
NOTE CONF
It turns out that if you're trying to reverse this
brownie in motion, there are uh As you make the
NOTE CONF
time step smaller between reverse steps and going from the
state of molecules at some time T to just a
NOTE CONF
tiny bit before time T minus 1, the Gaussian distribution
is actually a reasonable assumption of how to reverse Brownian
NOTE CONF
motion in a very small time window, OK.
Don't worry if you didn't follow that.
NOTE CONF
That's beyond the scope of this course.
This is a justification to say that this is not
NOTE CONF
an unreasonable assumption, but, uh, even if that Brownian motion
thing wasn't true, we would probably still just choose a
NOTE CONF
normal distribution because uh then we're just going to put
it on the neural networks.
NOTE CONF
You and Sigma to learn something.
Of high capacity enough to model the distribution of X
NOTE CONF
of T minus 1 given X of T.
All right.
NOTE CONF
Questions there.
OK, so that is step 2, reverse process.
NOTE CONF
I needed to parameterize the reverse process and define it.
The definition of the reverse process was this graphical model
NOTE CONF
where at every single step we're going to subtract away
some of the noise.
NOTE CONF
And to write out this reverse process, I needed to
write.
NOTE CONF
This, the reverse process graph factor rises according to this
distribution and then to be able to actually write this
NOTE CONF
out, I have to define PXT minus 1 given X
of T.
NOTE CONF
This is a free choice to me and I just
chose it to be a Gaussian distribution, a normal distribution
NOTE CONF
because Those are easy distributions to work with, right?
And they are not reasonable assumptions and empirically they're going
NOTE CONF
to work out as well.
All right, so that's step 2.
NOTE CONF
Now we come to probably the most involved part, which
is the elbow derivation.
NOTE CONF
All right.
So we have to find a 44 process.
NOTE CONF
Those are my cues.
We defined the graph of the reverse process.
NOTE CONF
And we define that in this reverse process.
These distributions I need to know to write out this
NOTE CONF
density are going to be Gaussian with neural network means
and neural network covariances just like in the VAE.
NOTE CONF
Now, I need a way to set the parameters of
data so I can actually reverse this distribution well, reverse
NOTE CONF
this, uh sorry, reverse this diffusion process well, reverse the
forward process well.
NOTE CONF
And so to do that, I need a loss function.
That tells me how do I change data.
NOTE CONF
So that These neural network means and covariances are actually
doing the work of changing pure Gaussian noise into an
NOTE CONF
actual image for my distribution, right?
So I need a loss function to optimize these data.
NOTE CONF
Questions there.
All right.
NOTE CONF
This will be that loss function derivation.
So today, we're just going to do a few steps
NOTE CONF
of it.
We're going to finish this next time, but we'll at
NOTE CONF
least do the first few steps.
When I taught this last year, um, People got lost
NOTE CONF
really quickly, so I totally revamped these slides and basically
for every single step I'm going to tell you the
NOTE CONF
why of where this step comes from.
So literally for every single step, it'll be followed by
NOTE CONF
a Y and I'll write out the the the the
steps.
NOTE CONF
So you guys will truly understand or be at least
have the notes to understand every single step of this
NOTE CONF
derivation, right?
And so, um, just like the VAE, where do we
NOTE CONF
start from?
We start from log likelihood.
NOTE CONF
Since we're calling this a loss, I'm going to put
a minus sign and say it's gonna be minus, uh,
NOTE CONF
log likelihood, negative log likelihood, all right.
Um, this is, this expression right here is a negative
NOTE CONF
log likelihood of an image X0 under our model distribution
under our entire reverse diffusion process with neural network parameters
NOTE CONF
data that denoise images.
OK, so we would, we would like to make this
NOTE CONF
X0, this image that we generate.
As likely, sorry, this X this is not an image
NOTE CONF
that we generate X0 is an image from like CA
10 for example.
NOTE CONF
We would like to change our model parameters data so
that when I put an actual image from CA 10,
NOTE CONF
it has high likelihood under my model parameters.
OK, so this is where we're going to start off.
NOTE CONF
This is always the or this is the lost function
of maximum likelihood that we used last quarter for.
NOTE CONF
Our softmax classifiers and we used uh this quarter for
VAEs right.
NOTE CONF
This Expression is intractable to right out.
Because just like the VAE's, if you try to actually
NOTE CONF
write out the product of all of these Gaussians that
are parameterized by neural networks.
NOTE CONF
You won't have an expression that you can actually just
write down by hand and so because we cannot evaluate
NOTE CONF
this expression tractably we have to do exactly what we
did for VAE, which is to write a tractable lower
NOTE CONF
bound to it and then we're going to try to
optimize that lower bound.
NOTE CONF
Questions there.
OK.
NOTE CONF
The first few steps of this are going to look
exactly like the VAE derivation.
NOTE CONF
So the first thing that I'm going to do is
I'm going to wrap this negative log likelihood and an
NOTE CONF
expectation under this distribution Q of X1 to T given
X0.
NOTE CONF
Right, this Q of X1 to T given X0, that's
actually the same Q that parameter, that's the same that
NOTE CONF
describes the forward process of diffusion.
The way we can do this is exactly the way
NOTE CONF
we did it for the VAE.
This is the expected log likelihood trick.
NOTE CONF
So P theta of X0 does not depend on.
X1 X2, X3, all the way to big XT.
NOTE CONF
And so it can come outside of the expectation.
In other words, if I take this expression and I
NOTE CONF
read it out.
This is going to be written over here.
NOTE CONF
Um, so this expectation is going to be the integral
of Q of X1 to T given X0 since that's
NOTE CONF
the distribution I'm taking the expectation with respect to.
I'm going to have a minus log p theta.
NOTE CONF
And then I have to integrate over all possible values
of the distribution.
NOTE CONF
So my integral will be over all values X1 to
XT.
NOTE CONF
This log p theta X0 does not have any X1
to XT, and so it can come outside of the
NOTE CONF
integral.
So I'm going to bring minus log p theta X0
NOTE CONF
outside of the integral, and now I'm integrating a probability
distribution over random vectors X1 to XT.
NOTE CONF
Integrating out all X1 to XT.
So by law of total probability, this thing equals 1
NOTE CONF
and therefore this expected log likelihood equals the actual negative
log likelihood.
NOTE CONF
Questions there.
OK, that's step one, we'll do one more step here.
NOTE CONF
So, um, the next step will be Again, the same
stuff that we did in the VAE, we're now going
NOTE CONF
to write out P theta X0 via my chain rule.
And so this comes from the chain rule of probability.
NOTE CONF
I know that if I write um P X 0
to T.
NOTE CONF
So why am I writing X0 to T?
I'm wanting to incorporate all the images across all time
NOTE CONF
into this expression to make simplifications later.
So PX0 to T is by the chain rule p
NOTE CONF
theta of X0 times p theta of the remaining variables
X1 to T given X of 0.
NOTE CONF
So then I divide both sides by this expression and
then I give you p of X0 equals PX0 to
NOTE CONF
T divided by P X quantity given X0.
Questions there.
NOTE CONF
All right, so we'll come back on Wednesday and we'll
continue on this proof.
NOTE CONF